what's up and rates me Greg Miller
alongside mr. multi-player Alfredo Diaz
Greg today we're looking at a game that
people say why do you still play well
you know what a lot of people still do a
distant is boring send my people know
this I do get that point but in the
beginning it was like all right there's
a lot of fog mechanics but the gameplay
the court was solid now especially with
this it they've just been they listened
to the audience yeah just update on
updates on updated that just made the
game people out there didn't know
Alfredo Diaz addicted to destiny yeah
plays it all it's an addicting game and
no I understand that's what everybody
talked to with destiny don't say the
same thing they play it right because
they want to go out and play with their
friends yeah I want to do all these cool
things when I collect gear in what do
the weeklies their nightfall is that's
the thing like that when people call
yeah I hate it when people say oh
destiny you know it's like this MMO and
then people get mad at them in order to
mow mow it has so many MMO tendencies of
dailies and weeklies in raising like
that it's the gear treadmills getting
you another I mean right here we're
looking at the new supers yay right well
hold on let's not even get into I want
you to write I want you to we're gonna
win back a little bit more for people
who don't know anything is happening
what is happening in the taken king so
in the taken king right yeah um it's
Oryx yes so Oryx is the taken king
himself that's crota yeah that's Oryx
son you kill him with his own sword yeah
that we get to see a little flashback
right here right exactly I'm not too
happy about that that's wise up you're
no worse than drinking me about this
destiny is really known for story right
oh you you know you didn't you run
around you you'll enjoy your saying i
hope i get the job i hope this kidding i
didn't get the drop I hate this game
i'll see you guys morning yeah but
destiny what little story there has been
it yet been a lot about like Gardens
going up like going and like you know
wrecking shop cleaning the house up your
sharing getting with all the dirt here
you're being hunted like because horse
pissed oh yeah right he's got his own
little army and he's sending them out
against you and then luckily you got
cool supers like oh my god the Hunter
has like a bow now that's all that's the
Warlock he's got like a like a lightning
time versus a temper and then what is
like a headbutt got a cool hatchet
brohamer fire with my early fire
like this is crazy it looks like this
looks sweet and oh my god throws it
that's I mean you say that they're
listening is this stuff you guys have
been demanding you want new supers you
want you stop okay we want new abilities
new supers right that just carries over
to all aspects of the game of growth
we're gonna get new exotics yeah yeah
we're gonna have new things a hunt down
new shaders shaders new ships and
whatnot ps4 players get that exclusive
like cooperative strike and some
exclusive gear yeah no but um man I'm
excited this look meaty how do you feel
about the rumors that it's gonna cost
like 40 bucks mmm that's not was not it
was neither confirmed nor denied today
on the PlayStation here's the thing Greg
yeah if you can buy call duty every year
right what's you know by destination
what oh yeah what's what this is a
Disney destiny is not a subscription
service of course as I'm sure you know
you are and this is gonna be a whole
game but it's rumored to be forty
dollars i think if it's like if it's
meaty enough then it could be worth it
but you've got to give me a lot of
content right they just give me a couple
strikes that'll make you something
without it looking you know looking in
from the outside looking in I think it
looks like it's gonna give you 40 bucks
worth and that's the other thing too is
like I the people who love Destin you're
gonna buy this in love it you were gonna
buy it Brennan's gonna buy it Frank is
gonna buy it everyone who plays destiny
every night like crazy people we're
gonna buy this and then go have fun and
do all their different rates and do all
the different things exactly how many
hours of gameplay have you gotten out of
your 16 dollar purchases 1,000 see I
mean a lot of people like how can you
play destiny for so long i play pvp so
at that point the multiplayer game then
you just double much hours into that's
how I do it that's the secret alfredo
mm-hmm mr. multiplayer I look so it
looks like wouldn't get some story yeah
it's a lot of fans want right it looks
like written get the usual gear you know
new super so that's awesome that's
something we haven't even gotten a taste
of previously and sold your soul I'm
sold your soul for 40 but if that's what
it exit been I'm em sold for the most
part all right ladies and gentlemen that
is the taken King coming up September
15th let us know what you think of it
keep watching this
you